MUCH FOR JOINING US FOR OUR
REGULAR SCHEDULE BMP MEETING AND.
THE CHAIR NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF
A QUORUM SO BEGIN AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. AND WILL.
BEGIN BY WELCOMING.
IN FILE ORDER A FILE ORDER.
.
I'VE NUMBER ONE WHICH IS S. B.
SEVENTY I SENATOR BASS.
PLEASE.
KILEY COME UP AND JOIN US.
AND AGAIN THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE S. B. SEVENTY.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS LA
PLACEMENT TO BE HERE FORGOT
ABOUT HOW BIG THIS REMAINS SO
HERE KIND OF FAR AWAY THAT. GOOD
GOOD AUDIO OFFERS I WANT TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS
AS AMENDED.
SORRY.
AS AMENDED S. B. SEVENTY IS A
VERY NARROW BILL THAT SIMPLY
ALLOWS FOR A CLIENT TO SHERRY
RESTRICTED APPRAISAL REPORT WAS
SPECIFIC RECIPIENTS SOUGHT RISK
RECENT MMS ADDED A SUNSET DATE.
OF JANUARY OFFERS TWENTY TWENTY
AND A SPECIAL DISCLOSURE
PROVISION TO CLARIFY THE REPORTS
ARE SHORTENED AND DO NOT HAVE
ALL THE INFORMATION FROM THE
APPRAISERS WORK FILE.
OUR THIS EXEMPTION WOULD NOT BE
ALLOWED FOR A FEDERALLY RELATED
TRANSACTION A LOAN A REFINANCE
ON RESIDENTIAL PROPERTY OR LOAN
OF INVESTOR FUNDS ARRANGED BY
MORTGAGE BROKER. AS SUCH THE
REPORTS THAT WILL ONLY GO TO
CLIENTS WHO REQUEST RESTRICTED
APPRAISAL REPORTS BECAUSE THEY
DO NOT NEED TO. FULL APPRAISAL
REPORTS THIS IS A VERY SMALL
POPULATION.
MIGHT MELODIOUS HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE APPRAISAL
INSTITUTE THE LARGEST APPRAISAL
OF ORGANIZATION IN THE NATION.
AND ULTIMATELY S. B. SEVENTY
ENSURES THAT MORE CONSUMERS ARE
USING LICENSED APPRAISERS AND
LOWER COSTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME AND IF THERE
ARE ANY QUESTIONS. MISTER BELOW
IS HERE TO. ANSWER THOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MIKE
BILLOWED ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA GOVERNENT RELATIONS
COMMITTEE OF THE APPRAISAL
INSTITUTE IT'S NOT VERY OFTEN
THAT GROUPS COME BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE AND ASK FOR
PERMISSION. TO SELL AND LESS
EXPENSIVE STREAMLINED PRODUCT.
THE REASON WHY WE'RE DOING THAT
IS BECAUSE THERE IS CONSUMER
DEMAND
FOUR SHORTENED APPRAISAL REPORTS
THAT ARE NOT INVOLVED IN
FEDERALLY RELATED TRANSACTIONS.
AND THERE'S ONLY ONE PROBLEM
WITH THE UNIFORM STANDARDS OF
PROFESSIONAL APPRAISAL PRACTICE
TO WHICH ALL LICENSEES MUST
COMPLY AND THAT IS THEY CAN DO A
RESTRICTED REPORT BUT ONLY IF IT
ONLY HAS ONE INTENDED USER.
SO FINALLY APPRAISAL APPRAISER
AND I WANT TO DO A RESTRICTED
REPORT FOR YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
I FIND OUT IT IS FOR YOU AND
YOUR LAWYER OR YOU AND YOUR
FAMILY. YOU AND THE IRS
CAN'T DO IT.
ONLY EXEMPTION FROM THE UNIFORM
STANDARDS IN THIS BILL IS TO
ALLOW MORE THAN ONE INTENDED
USER. WHEN THERE IS CONSENT BY
THE CLIENT SO IT ALLOWS A
LICENSED APPRAISER TO RESPOND TO
CONSUMER DEMAND.
WE PUT LOTS OF PROTECTIONS IN
THERE INCLUDING WORKING WITH
YOUR COMMITTEE AND FOR THAT
REASON WE WOULD ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME SEEN NO WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME SENATOR
BASED YOU WISH TO CLOSE.
I THINK IDEA TO A LITTLE
PREMATURELY BUT I'D LIKE TO
RESPECTFULLY ANSWERING AYE VOTE.
WONDERFUL AND WE WILL ADDRESS
AND TAKE A VOTE WHEN WE HAVE A
QUORUM THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ATTENDED BATES AND.
SINCE YOU'RE ALSO HERE DO YOU
WISH TO ALSO PRESENT ON A FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE WHICH IS S. B.
ELEVEN. OWN YES I WOULD LIKE TO
THINK THAT MY WITNESSES ARE HERE
I THINK.
JOINING ME UP HERE.
S. B. ELEVEN NO NINE SEEKS TO
ADDRESS THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC BY
PROVIDING PREVENTIVE EDUCATION
OFF FOR ALL. ITS SPECIFICALLY
REQUIRES THE EXISTING ARE
CONTINUING EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS FOR PRESCRIBERS.
TO INCLUDE THE RISKS OF
ADDICTION AN OVERDOSE ASSOCIATED
WITH THE USE OF SCHEDULED TO
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES. HE
REQUIRES A FLAG OR OTHER
NOTIFICATION MECHANISM MECHANISM
ON ALL SCHEDULED TWO CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE SUBSTANCE
PRESCRIPTION BOTTLES. ON THE
ASSOCIATED ADDICTION OVERDOSE
RISKS IT REQUIRES A DISCUSSION
WITH THE PRESCRIBER FOR ANY
MINOR RECEIVING AN ISSUE INITIAL
OPIOID PRESCRIPTION. AND LASTLY
S. B. ELEVEN ON NINE REQUIRES AN
INFORMATION SHEET
ON THE RISKS OF OPIOIDS TO BE
SIGNED BY A MINOR ATHLETE. IN
THEIR PARENTS OR GUARDIAN BEFORE
PARTICIPATION BY ORGANIZED
SPORTS TEAM ACCORDING TO THE
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL
FIFTY THREE THOUSAND. AMERICANS
DIED FROM OPIOID OR OVERDOSES
AND TWENTY FIFTEEN WHICH TOTALS
MORE DEATHS THAN CAR ACCIDENTS
IN THAT SAME YEAR. EVEN MORE
ALARMED ALARMING IS THE FACT
THAT THE CURRENT DEATH COUNT
EXCEEDS THE MEMBER. NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE KILLED IN
THE VIETNAM WAR.
CALIFORNIA HOW JUST SHY OF TWO
THOUSAND NINE OPIOID RELATED
DEATHS AND TWENTY SIXTEEN. WITH
TWELVE PERCENT OF THOSE BEING IN
SANDIEGO COUNTY PART OF MY
DISTRICT. INSURING PATIENTS
MINERS AND THEIR PARENTS HAVE
THE NECESSARY INFORMATION BEFORE
TAKING THESE MEDICATIONS WILL
HELP PREVENT FUTURE ADDICTIONS
AND OVERDOSES WITH THE DRUGS.
I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS WHO THAT HAVE
WORKED WITH US AND CRAFTING THE
BILL SO FAR. WE ARE SINCERELY
APPRECIATIVE OF THAT
COLLABORATION REPRESENTING THE
SAN DIEGO DA TODAY AS DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY LARA COUNTY.
SHE WILL ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. IN
ADDITION WE ARE THANKFUL TO HAVE
JUDY BARBER. I HEAR FROM MY
DISTRICT TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF ELEVEN OH NINE.
AND SURE HER SON'S PERSONAL
STORY WITH OPIOIDS AND THANK YOU
MEMBERS I DO LOOK FORWARD BITE
YOUR QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF WE
KINDLY ASK YOU TO PAUSE FOR JUST
ONE MOMENT SO WE CAN ESTABLISH A
QUORUM.
WE SECURING.
LOW. HERE BROWN. ARAMBULA. BAKER.
BLOOM.
CHEN.
JILL.
CUNNINGHAM. EGGMAN.
FOOTBALL.
GIPSON.
GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
MCCARTY.
MEDINA MULLIN. OBERNOLTE.
TING.
THANK YOU WE'VE ESTABLISHED A
CORPSMAN NOW WILL ALLOW UP TO
THREE MINUTES IN TOTAL A FOR
YOUR PUPPY TEST MY SO. PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO BEGIN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. I THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR HAVING ME THIS IS A
POSTER OF FACES. OF BEAUTIFUL
JUST A FEW OF I'M JUST SO OF
BEAUTIFUL YOUNG ADULTS WHO
PASSED AWAY IN ORANGE COUNTY
WHERE I LIVE I LIVE I'M FROM
LOOKING IN THE GAL. AND THIS IS
MY SON JARED. AND THESE ARE ALL
THAT'S VERY CLOSE FRIENDS THAT
HE GREW UP WITH THEM IN THE TOP
ROW. AND THEY PASSED AWAY FROM
AN OVERDOSE ALL OF THEM.
.
IT WAS PREVENTABLE AND THIS IS
WHY I'M HERE.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY MY NAME IS JODY
BARBER I'M FROM LAGUNA NIGUEL
CALIFORNIA.
S. B. ELEVEN ON NINE IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
I LOST MY NINETEEN YEAR OLD SON
AND FOUR OF THOSE CLOSE FRIENDS
IN TWO THOUSAND TEN. AND SOON
BECAME AN ADVOCATE AGAINST THE
OVER PRESCRIBING. OF
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS.
HIS FRIEND WHO PASSED AWAY WAS
INJURED PLAYING FOOTBALL. AND
WAS PRESCRIBED SIXTEEN ARCO FOR
A MINOR INJURY THAT COULD HAVE
BEEN RELIEVED BY TAKING ADVIL
AND TYLENOL.
ANOTHER YOUNG MAN WHO WAS NOW
GONE TOO SOON CRIED TO ME SAYING
HE WAS HOOKED ON NARCOS.
AFTER HE TOOK.
AFTER HE TWO IS INJURED PLAYING
FOOTBALL HE WAS A FRESHMAN ON
THE VARSITY TEAM HE SAID TO ME.
WHITE IN THE DOCTOR ASKED ME IF
ADDICTION RUNS IN THIS FAMILY.
BOTH HIS PARENTS ARE ADDICTED TO
PRESCRIPTION PILLS HIS DREAMS OF
BECOMING A PRO FOOTBALL PLAYER
WERE SHATTERED.
ANOTHER YOUNG MAN MENTIONED HE
BROKE HIS ANKLE PLAYING
BASKETBALL AND WAS GIVEN BY
KEVIN.
THAT'S WHEN HIS ADDICTION
STARTED AND HIS LIFE BECAME A
NIGHTMARE.
THE LIST GOES ON AND ON.
MY SON WAS SIXTEEN WHEN HE BROKE
HIS COLLARBONE WHILE DIRT BIKING
AND THE NURSE GAVE HIM A BIKE
AND. HE COULDN'T STOP.
HIS FRIEND I MENTIONED HE WAS
PRESCRIBED SIXTEEN ARCO WAS SEEN
DOCTOR LISA SAYING.
HE WAS WALKING OUT OF HER OFFICE
IN LESS THAN FIVE MINUTES WITH
SCRIPTS FOR APADANA.
XANAX BY GIVEN ANYTHING HE
WANTED.
NINETY UPON IN A BOTTLE.
MY SON AND HIS FRIENDS WERE
ADDICTED TO OXYMORPHONE AND DIED
WITH THAT HIGHLY ADDICTIVE
STRONG MEDICATION INTENDED FOR
TERMINAL STAGE CANCER IN THEIR
SYSTEM.
A WARNING LABEL THAT STATES
CAUTION.
OP AT RISK OF OVERDOSE AND
ADDICTION WILL IN FACT SAVE
LIVES.
THANK YOU ONE MINUTE LEFT.
WHAT ELEVEN TOTAL?
I SEE SEVENTH GRADERS WITH ARMS
OR LEGS CAST AND I ASK WHAT WAS
DESCRIBED IN THE PARENTS TAMI
BIKE AND WITHOUT ANY CONCERN ON
THEIR FACES.
AS AN EFFORT TO EDUCATE KIDS
TEENS AND YOUNG ADULTS ARE
PRODUCED A SHORT DOCUMENTARY
CALLED OVERTAKEN.
YOUNG ADULTS TALK ABOUT HOW THE
BECAME ADDICTED TO OPIATES AFTER
SPORT INJURY. THIS FILM IS USED
IN SCHOOLS REHABS DO YOU AYE
CLASSES AND COURTROOMS.
I WOULD LIKE OVERTAKEN US PART
OF THE EDUCATION FOR PATIENTS
STUDENTS PARENTS I'M PRESCRIBERS.
WE'RE ASKING FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
ON S. B. ELEVEN NO NINE THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WE HAVE
TEN SECONDS LEFT YOU WISHED WE
WOULD ALLOW IT TO THIRTY SIX IF
YOU WISH TO HAPPENED ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
INDICATE THAT I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF.
SUMMER STAFF AND DISTRICT
ATTORNEY OF SAN DIEGO AND WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
CARRYING THIS LEGISLATION WOULD
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND WE APPRECIATE YOU
COMING HERE TODAY.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF NAME AND
FILIATION IF YOU WISH TO DO SO.
I'M
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ZACHARY
CORBEAU WITH THE CALIFORNIA DOWN
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR BRING FORWARD.
JENNIFER SO MOST OF THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
TIFFANY MATTHEWS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
MAKE AN ORIGAMI HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARKUP PREY ON BEHALF
OF MCKESSON CORPORATION AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT SETON ANY
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME.
SENOR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEM NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND A
DOCTOR AND.
SENATOR BATES AYE.
WANTED TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS LEGISLATION
FORWARD OPIOIDS ARE A REAL
CRISIS THAT WE'RE FACING IN OUR
STATE AND OUR COUNTRY AND THIS
IS A VITAL PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
WHEN THE OPPORTUNITY ARISES IF I
CAN JOIN AS A CO AUTHOR I WOULD
LIKE TO.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO.
HAVING THIS BILL CAN CERTAINLY
FORWARD INVITE ALL OF YOU WERE
INTERESTED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BYE SURE
BROKE. UP THANK YOU SHARE ABOUT
MY SENATOR THANK YOU FOR BEING A
LEADER ON THIS ISSUE AND.
SEVERAL BILLS FOR.
AND ALSO WANTED KNOWLEDGE JODY
WHO LIVES IN OUR COMMUNITY SHE'S
BEEN A REAL LEADER AND AN ORANGE
COUNTY ON THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR HARD WORK
ON THIS GOOD TO SEE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS A COMMENT
AT THIS TIME.
SENATOR BASED YOU WISH TO CLOSE
I JUST A QUICK CUP PERSONAL
STORY ON MY DAUGHTER WAS INJURED
HAND JOB WAS PRESCRIBED. AN
OPIOID YET DIDN'T WORK WELL WITH
HER SHE JUST TOOK ONE CENTIMETER.
CRAZY SO BUT I HAVE TO WORRY IT
WAS IT WAS NOT OPIOID AND I SAID
IT WAS AN OPIOID I THINK THERE
IS A CONFUSION THAT PEOPLE THINK
OPIOID IS THE DRUG. RATHER THAN
THE CLASSIFICATION SO I THINK
THAT SAID DUCATION PROGRAM IS
THE FIRST STEP IN A REALLY
IMPORTANT OR ACTION IN TERMS OF
PEOPLE UNDERSTANDING WHAT IT IS
THEY'RE TAKING SO. AGAIN MANY
MANY MANY THANKS TO THE MANY
STAKEHOLDERS BECAUSE WE WORKED
THROUGH A LOT OF THE CONCERNS I
THINK WE'VE ARRIVED AT SOMETHING
WILL BE VERY HELPFUL SO I.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THIS AS YOU KNOW SENATOR BATES
JOINS WITH A NUMBER OF VARIOUS
BILLS WITH RESPECT ADDRESSING
THE OPENING CRISIS IN BOTH
HOUSES AND WE KNOW THAT THIS
ISSUE TRANSCENDS PARTY
AFFILIATION AND. THEIR
RESPECTIVE HOUSES AND SO WE VERY
MUCH HOPE TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
TO A FURTHER ADVANCE MEASURES
THAT WOULD HELP ADDRESS THE IT
THE WAY CRISIS FOR YOUNGER
PATIENTS AND ABOVE TOO SO. I'M
VERY MUCH I JOIN IN SUPPORT AND
RECOMMENDATION OF OF SUCH WE
HAVE A MOTION BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON IS OUR SECOND.
BUT BY SECOND BY A DOCTOR
ARAMBULA COMMITTEE SICKBAY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BUSH IS TO PASS THE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH LOW. AYE LOW AYE PEROT
BROKE AYE ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE
BAKER. BAKER AYE BLOOM. BLOOM
AYE CHAN CHEN AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
AYE EGGMAN.
AND WHEN I FALL FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
MCCARTY. MEDINA MEDINA AYE
MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE. OBERNOLTE AYE TING.
THE BILL CRIME HAS FOURTEEN AYE
VOTES IN THE LEAGUE THERE OPEN
FOR ABSENT.
THANK YOU ALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IN THE DEBATES.
WE NOW MOVE ON.
TO.
.
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE.
WHICH IS S. B. TEN ZERO THREE
BY SENATOR ROTH.
WELCOME THANK YOU AS CHAIR
MEMBERS.
THIS BILL AUTHORIZES THE
RESPIRATORY CARE BOARD TO
IDENTIFY THREE LEVELS OF
RESPIRATORY CARE. BASIC
INTERMEDIATE AND ADVANCED.
CURLY RESPIRATORY CARE
PRACTITIONERS DUTIES CAN RANGE
FROM EDUCATING CONSUMERS ABOUT
RESPIRATORY CARE TO
ADMINISTERING. PHARMACOLOGICAL
UNDIAGNOSED DIAGNOSTIC AGENTS
RELATED TO RESPIRATORY CARE
TREATMENTS.
THE BILL DOES NOT ALTER THE
CURRENT SCOPE OF PRACTICE FOR
RESPIRATORY CARE PRACTITIONERS
IT MERELY ALLOWS THE BOARD TO
CLARIFY THESE THREE LEVELS OF
CARE. FOR RESPIRATORY THERAPY.
THE BOARD'S BEEN GETTING A LOT
OF QUESTIONS WITH RESPECT WHO
CAN DO WHAT AND THIS BILL SHOULD
ASSIST
NOW THAT PROCESS.
I HAVE STEPHANIE NUNEZ
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
RESPIRATORY CARE BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA HERE WITH ME TODAY TO
ANSWER ANY PARTICULAR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS.
A YOU MAY HAVE AND I
RESPECTFULLY AS FROM AYE VOTE AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN LOW IN
MEMBERS I AM STEPHANIE NUNEZ I'M
THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
RESPIRATORY CARE BOARD. I SP ONE
ZERO ZERO THREE ADDRESSES THE
EXPANSION OF THE PRACTICE OF
RESPIRATORY CARE SINCE THE PORTS
INCEPTION IN NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO.
SPECIFICALLY S. B. TEN OVER
THREE PROVIDES AN AVENUE FOR THE
BOARD TO IDENTIFY TASKS AND
PROCEDURES AT VARIOUS LEVELS
THAT WILL SERVE AS A GUIDE TO
FACILITIES.
AS TO WHERE ADDITIONAL TRAINING
AND ARE COMPETENT TESTING MAY BE
NEEDED THROUGH THE RC PIECE
EMPLOYER.
FURTHER THIS LEGISLATION MAY
PROVE FRUITFUL IN PROVIDING A
PATHWAY FOR PAID ON THE JOB
TRAINING FOR THE MOST BASIC PASS
AS AN ADJUNCT TO FORMAL
EDUCATION AND TRAINING.
S. B. TEN OF THREE WILL HELP
IDENTIFY THREE LEVELS OF TASK
AND PROCEDURES WITHIN THE
PRACTICE OF RESPIRATORY CARE.
REGULATIONS PRODUCT PROMULGATED
AS A RESULT WILL PROVIDE GREATER
FLEXIBILITY TO FACILITIES BROWN
CHURNING CONSUMER SAFETY IS
RECOGNIZED.
THE RESPIRATORY CARE BOARD
SUPPORTS THE SPELL.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN A MEMBERS
JENNIFER TANNA HELL WITH AARON
REGION ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY.
FOR RESPIRATORY CARE
RESPIRATORY CARE PRACTITIONERS
WORK WITH INFANTS.
AT TO THE ELDERLY ALL PATIENTS
I'M AND WERE HAPPY TO CO SPONSOR
THIS BILL WITH THE BOARD PRESS
VERY CAREPRACTITIONERS HAVE
SPECIALIZED TRAINING AND CARDIO
CARDIOLOGY IN PULMONOLOGY. AND
WORK WITH PATIENTS IN INTENSIVE
CARE UNITS OPERATING ROOMS
OUTPATIENT CLINICS SLEEP CLINICS
AND HOME HEALTH ENVIRONMENTS
EVOLVING TECHNOLOGY AND ADVANCES
IN BEST PRACTICE CARE. OUR BEST
PATIENT CARE ARE DRIVING MANY
CHANGES TO OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
C. S. R. C. WHAT'S THE BOARD TO
BE PREPARED FOR THOSE CHANGES BY
HAVING THE BOARD OUTLINED WHAT
ARE BASIC INTERMEDIATE AND
ADVANCED RESPIRATORY TESTS AND
PROCEDURES. THIS WILL ESTABLISH
A FOUNDATION ON WHICH TO RESPOND
TO ANY FUTURE EDUCATION DEMANDS
OF THE INDUSTRY. CLEARQUEST
YOU'RE RIGHT THOUGH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
CNN ANY WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME.
SEEING NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM CAN HUNDREDS.
SEEING OAK A QUESTIONS A COMMENT
SENATOR ROTH YOU WISH TO CLOSE
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU VERY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND SENATE ROTH WE UNDERSTAND
THAT OF THIS DOES NOT IMPACT ANY
OTHER HEALTH CARE LICENSEES IN
THAT ANY ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS
ON EDUCATION WOULD REQUIRE.
ANOTHER PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT'S CORRECT THAT'S ABSOLUTE
CORRECT WONDERFUL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATE ROTH THIS DOES ENJOY
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION THERE'S
BEEN A MOTION AND A SECOND.
RESEARCHER WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
MUCH AS DID PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS LOW I'D LOW
EYEBROW. BROUGH AYE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BAKER BAKER AYE
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG. FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
MCCARTY.
MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE. OBERNOLTE AYE TING.
TING AYE.
THAT BILL HAS FIFTEEN VOTES WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CENTER ROTH WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR WHICH IS
S. B. TEN FORTY TWO. BY SENATOR
MONEY.
SENATE MONNING WELCOME PLEASE
BECAUSE IT WOULD APPEAR AT A
GOOD MORNING AND MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS.
THANK YOU.
THE CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE
BOARD LICENSES AND REGULATES
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
FIVE THOUSAND CONTRACTORS IN
CALIFORNIA.
RECEIVES NEARLY TWENTY THOUSAND
COMPLAINTS ANNUALLY.
IN THE LAST FEW YEARS THE CSL BE
COST TO ADMINISTER CITATIONS
HAVE GROWN SIGNIFICANTLY. ISSUES
MORE THAN TWO THOUSAND CITATIONS
A YEAR APPROXIMATELY FORTY
PERCENT OF THE CITATIONS ARE
APPEALED WITH THE AVERAGE COST
PER APPEALED CITATION. BEING
ABOUT TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS.
SENATE BILL TEN FORTY TWO WILL
ALLOW THE CONTRACTORS STATE
LICENSE BOARD TO HOST INFORMAL
CITATION APPEAL CONFERENCES TO
RESOLVE ADMINISTRATOR CITATIONS
IT ISSUES TO LICENSED AND
UNLICENSED CONTRACTORS.
PRIOR TO A FORMAL APPEAL.
THROUGH AN ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARING THIS BILL ALLOWS THE CSL
BE TO EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY REGULATE CONTRACTORS
IN CALIFORNIA. MEMBERS ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION ON THE
BILL WITH THE CHAIRS PERMISSION
I'D LIKE TO PRESENT. MISTER JIM
NETSKY CHIEF OF LEGISLATION FOR
THE C. SLB.
YES WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH YES AYE THIS BILL
WOULD AUTHORIZE THE REGISTRAR TO
SETTLE LESS EGREGIOUS CITATIONS
PRIOR TO AN ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARING OR AYE IN LIEU OF AN
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARING WHEN
APPROPRIATE. IT WOULD NOT BE
APPROPRIATE IF THERE'S A
FINANCIAL INJURY IN THE CASE
THOSE WITHOUT A HEARING.
REALLY WHAT THIS WILL DO IS
ALLOW ARAB FOR PAYMENT PLANS AND
REDUCED FINES AS TIME REQUESTED
OUR RESEARCH INDICATES WHEN A
CONTRACTOR ULTIMATELY GOES TO
THE EXPENSIVE. TIME CONSUMING
I'VE APPEALS PROCESS IT TURNS
OUT ALL THEY WANTED WAS A REDUCE
FINE I'M OR SOMEONE TO TALK TO
ABOUT THE CITATION THIS WILL BE
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO TELL
THEIR STORY. AND I RESOLVED THE
CITATION.
IN AN INFORMAL SETTING AND IT
DOES NOT ABROGATE THE RIGHT TO
APPEAL IF THE CONTRACTORS
DISSATISFIED WITH THE RESULTS
THE APA RIGHT IS INTACT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MARIA
GARCIA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LANDSCAPE CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION PROUD TO BE HERE IN
SUPPORT AS A MEANS TO HELP THE
DEPARTMENT. OR TO THE BOARD
EXCUSE ME CONSERVE RESOURCES AND
ALLOW THEM TO REALLY TARGET
EFFORTS AGAINST THE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY AND WE'RE LICENSE
CONTRACTORS AND THEN LICENSE
CONTRACTORS ARE REALLY OUT THERE
SKIRTING THE LAW ALLOWING THE
LICENSE TO. TO FOCUS THEIR
EFFORTS AND SUPPORT THINKING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WOODS IS WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
CNN ANY WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TINO
PETITION WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COULD YOU MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS ARE
CONSTANTLY MEMBERS THERE'S BEEN
A MOTION A SECOND AND SENATOR
MINING DO YOU WISH TO CLOSE JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AMBER'S THEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR PRESENTING THIS BILL TO
STREAMLINE THESE ENFORCEMENT
MEASURES.
MUSIC TRIP PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS LOW LIGHT LOW
EYEBROW. WELL I ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BAKER. BAKER AYE
BLOOM. BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU. CHU AYE
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN IPHONE.
FONG I GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN IRWIN AYE MCCARTY.
MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE TING.
TING AYE.
YOUR BILL HAS SIXTEEN VOTES SEND
OUR MONEY AND BELIEVE THE ROLE
OF OPEN FATSO MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEND MONEY
MEMBERS WHILE WE WAIT FOR ONE
ADDITIONAL AUTHOR ON FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO WILL GO THROUGH. UP
THE WALL AGAIN. AND WILL BEGIN
THEN WITH A.
NOW FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE I WHICH
IS S. B. SEVENTY AND WE NEED A
MOTION A SECOND.
THERE'S A MINIMAL XIN BY SOME
ARE GIPSON AND US A SECOND BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDINA.
RESEARCHER WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
S. B. SEVEN EMOTIONS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW
AYE AYE LOW EYEBROW. BROUGH AYE
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN IPHONE. FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN. IRWIN AYE MCCARTY.
MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE TING.
TING AYE.
AND THAT CURRENTLY HAS
STEAMBOAT ON LEAVE THOUGH ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS WILL GO
ON THEN FI ITEM NUMBER THREE.
WHICH IS S. B. TEN ZERO THREE BY
SENATOR ROTH.
S. BE TEN ZERO THREE MOTIONS DAY
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MCCARTY.
MULLIN.
THE SIXTEEN OF VOTES BELIEVE THE
ROLE OF AN OVERDRAFT MEMBERS
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE. S. B.
ELEVEN ó NINE BY SENATOR BATES.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MCCARTY.
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
TING AYE.
THAT BILL HAS SEVENTEEN VOTES
EMILY THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
AND NOW WE'LL MOVE ON THEN SO OF
A FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO WHICH IS
S. B. NINE EIGHTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR GALGIANI.
SENEGAL JENNY WELCOME PLEASE
PRESENT WHATEVER RIGHT GOOD MY
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
S. B. NINE EIGHTY EIGHT WILL
REQUIRE ALL HOME INSPECTORS TO
MAKE A WRITTEN NOTIFICATION IN
THEIR FINAL REPORT. IF YELLOW
CORRUGATED STAINLESS STEEL
TUBING IS SEEN DURING THE COURSE
OF THEIR INSPECTION.
THIS FLEXIBLE METAL GAS TUBING
IS BEEN INSTALLED IN OVER SIX
MILLION HOMES IN THE U. S. SINCE
THE EARLY NINETEEN NINETIES IT'S
USED TO SUPPLY NATURAL GAS OR
PROPANE TO FURNACES WATER
HEATERS AND OTHER GAS APPLIANCES.
DIRECTOR INDIRECT LIGHTNING
STRIKES ON OR NEAR STRUCTURE
HAVE BEEN SHOWN TO CAUSE
ELECTRICAL SERGE TO TRAVEL INTO
THE STRUCTURE. AND HAVE IN SOME
CASES BECAUSE TO PUNCTURE IN THE
SIDEWALL OF THE YELLOW TO BEING
AS THE ENERGY ARCS FROM ONE
METALLIC SYSTEM TO ANOTHER
SEEKING GROUND. THIS BARKING CAN
IGNITE THE PRESSURIZED GAS
LEAKING FROM THE PUNCTURE AND
SOME CASES MAY LEAD TO FIRE.
WITH ME TODAY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ARE MARIA GARCIA AND
TOM SHE HE ON BEHALF OF THE
SPONSORS THE AIR CONDITIONING
HEATING AND REFRIGERATION
INSTITUTE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MARIA GARCIA HERE AGAIN
AND NOW ON BEHALF OF THE AIR
CONDITIONING HEATING AND
REFRIGERATION INSTITUTE HIV IS
THAT PROUD SPONSOR OF THIS
MEASURE AND VERY THANKFUL TO THE
AUTHOR IN IN CHAMPIONING THIS.
CONSUMER NOTIFICATION THIS YEAR
SHE EXPLAINED AT THE BILL VERY
WELL SO I WON'T BE REDUNDANT
THAT SIMPLY ASK ME I DON'T THINK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THAT'S
A TOUGH ACT TO FOLLOW.
OKAY. SMART MAN THAT ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
COME UP TO THE PODIUM AND WILL
ALLOW YOU UP TO. THREE MINUTES
.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS DAVID
PACE I AM THE LEGISLATIVE CHAIR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA REAL ESTATE
INSPECTION ASSOCIATION.
AND I'M A HOME INSPECTOR.
.
VERY BRIEFLY.
CREA IS SUPPOSED TO THIS BILL
FOR A NUMBER OF REASONS WE
BELIEVE IT. INAPPROPRIATELY
PLACES INTO LAW NOTIFICATION.
MANDATE ON HOME INSPECTORS THAT
IT IS THE RESPONSIBILITY.
THAT IS THE RESPONSIBILITY
MANUFACTURES TO EDUCATE AND
INFORM THEIR CUSTOMERS REGARDING
THEIR PRODUCTS.
WE BELIEVE IT INAPPROPRIATELY
PLACES AND A LOT A MANDATE THAT
A HOME INSPECTOR PLACE.
IN HIS OR HERREPORT THE BELIEF.
THAT MANUFACTURERS OF
MANUFACTURERS THE TUBING IS
SAFER.
IF PROPERLY BONDED AND GROUNDED
WE BELIEVE IT INAPPROPRIATELY
PLACES INTO LAW A REQUIREMENT
THAT HOME INSPECTORS.
IN EFFECT RECOMMEND THAT A
LICENSED ELECTRICAL CONTRACTOR
BE ENGAGED.
TO CONFIRM PROPER BONDING AND
GROUNDING WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
BILL IS IN MY TO.
IS PREMATURE.
AND THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE MORE
RESEARCH.
.
ON THE PART OF THE MANUFACTURERS.
AND THERE NEEDS TO BE MORE
AGREEMENT AMONG.
THE.
FOLKS THAT WRITE THE VARIOUS
CODES.
SO FOR THAT REASON.
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
I'D LIKE TO.
INTRODUCE SKIP WALKER.
I SKIP WALKER I'M OUT HOME
INSPECTOR CREA MEMBER. ALSO
GNASHING MEMBER WHICH IS
AMERICAN SOCIETY OF HOME
INSPECTORS BELONG TO. THE
INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL INSPECTORS.
AMONG OTHER THINGS AYE AYE
RIGHT OF. OUR CO AUTHOR A BOOK
ON ELECTRICAL CODE SO I WOULD
SAY I HAVE MORE THAN A PASSING
KNOWLEDGE OF WHAT FUNDING AND
GROUNDING IS I HAPPEN TO. BE
EXAMINED AND IF HE A MEMBER ALSO
THEY WRITE THE ELECTRIC CODE IN
THE UNITED STATES.
THAT CALIFORNIA'S ADOPTED I I
ACTUALLY ASKED THEM WHY THEY
WERE SILENT ON THE ISSUE OF
BONDING OF CSS T..
THE RESPONSE I RECEIVED AND I'M
GONNA PARAPHRASE SAID DON DURING
THE TWENTY ELEVEN CODE CYCLE.
CHO PANEL FIVE REJECTED A
PROPOSAL THE ROAD RECOMMENDED
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR A CSS T..
THE PANEL STATEMENT SUPPORTING
THE REJECTION PROPOSAL SAID CMP
FIVE IS NOT CONVINCED THE
BONDING TO AROUND PORTIONS OF
CSS T.. WILL SOLVE THE PROBLEM
NO TEST RECORDS WERE PROVIDED TO
SUBSTANTIATE THE ADEQUACY. OF
THE.
THE REQUIRED BONDING THE
PROBLEM COULD BE DIRECTLY
RELATED TO THE DESIGN AND WALL
THICKNESS OF CSS T.. THE PURPOSE
OF THE ENEMIES NEC WHICH IS THE
NATIONAL ELECTRIC CODE IS THE
PRACTICAL SAFEGUARDING OF
PERSONS PROPERTY FROM HAZARDS
ARISING FROM THE USE OF
ELECTRICITY.
WHAT THAT MEANS IN PLAIN PLAIN
ENGLISH IS THAT?
?
BONDING THE PURPOSE OF BONDING
IS TO PROTECT PEOPLE FROM THINGS
THAT THEY DO INSIDE THE HOUSE.
I HAVE A COLLEAGUE THAT WAS
INVOLVED IN THOSE DISCUSSIONS.
AND THIS IS THE WRITTEN RESPONSE
WHICH IS SORT OF WHAT THEY HAVE
FOR PUBLICATION. TENS OF THE
LIBERAL RESPONSE WAS SIMPLY THAT.
WE BOND FOR ELECTRICAL SAFETY
NOT FOR LIGHTNING.
AND THAT'S AN ABSOLUTE NOT
CORRECT STATEMENT AND THEY.
THEY FURTHER ACTUALLY SAID THAT.
IF THERE'S A PROBLEM WITH A
PRODUCT MAYBE YOU SHOULD
CONSIDER ADDRESSING THAT.
THE PROBLEM WITH THIS BILL VIDEO
NINE AS IT SOUNDS
THE OTHER TIMES THAT SENATE
TURNING LATER ON WILL.
WILL SAY THAT ARE REASONABLY.
HOME INSPECTORS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
SIR.
THANK YOU SO THAT YOU VERY MUCH
YOUR TIME'S UP THANK YOU MIGHT
MUCH APPRECIATED.
I NEED TO KNOW WHAT MRS WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO COME TO MIKE AT
NAME INFLATION IF YOU WISH TO DO
SO STEVE CAROLINE INCOMING A
TERM OF THE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE INSPECTED SO SOON LAWSUIT
ALSO HOME INSPECTOR IN A POST.
YES MY NAME IS JOHN TO MOTION I
MCCREA CALIFORNIA REAL ESTATE
INSPECTION ASSOCIATION HOME
INSPECTOR I'M ALSO AMERICAN
SOCIETY OF HOME INSPECTORS. AND
I AM IN COMPLETE OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL AS WELL AS OUR REGION
EIGHT WHICH REPRESENTS ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE HOME
INSPECTORS IN THE SOUTHERN PART
OF THE STATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION WILL GO BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. QUESTION FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAER. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I AM OF QUESTION
FOR BOTH THE.
THE PRO AND THE CON.
AND IN CENTER GALGIANI MAYBE YOU
YOU CAN ADDRESS HURT THAT
DETERMINES YOUR WITNESSES A
BETTER BUT.
IS THERE SOMETHING THAT LED THAT
YOU WHAT WHAT INSPIRED THIS WAS
THERE WAS THERE ARE A TERRIBLE
SOMETIMES WE HEAR ABOUT TERRIBLE
ACCIDENTS AND.
AND SOME.
WHY IS THIS A PROBLEM?
WHAT HAPPENED?
THANK YOU OF MISTER CHAIRMAN AND.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER THE
ANSWER IS YES.
THERE HAVE BEEN. A
UNFORTUNATELY THERE HAVE BEEN
DOCUMENTED DEATHS.
AS A RESULT OF OF THE PROBLEM
THAT THIS BILLS TRYING TO
ADDRESS SPECIFICALLY IN THE
STATE OF TEXAS.
LIGHTNING STRIKES HAVE RESULTED
IN.
OF FIRE AND DEATH.
FROM CSS T. YELLOW CSS TEETH A
TUBING THAT WASN'T PROPERLY
BONDED AND GROUNDED. OTHER HAVE
BEEN OTHER INCIDENTS THAT DIDN'T
RESULT IN DEATH BUT IT WAS AS A
RESULT OF THIS THAT THE INDUSTRY
STEPPED UP. AND WORK WITH THE
NATIONAL COUNCIL OF STATE
LEGISLATURES TO COME UP WITH
MODEL LANGUAGE
BUT TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE WHICH
IS A NOTIFICATION ISSUE SO THAT
HOMEOWNERS WHEN THEY'RE BUYING A
HOUSE. ARE AWARE THAT YOU LOOK
TO BECAUSE IN THE HOUSE WHAT THE
PROPER PROCEDURE IS TO MAKE SURE
THOSE PROPERLY BONDED. THE
LEGISLATION NOT THAT UNNECESSARY
MATTERS HERE CALIFORNIA WITHOUT
MODEL LEGISLATION HAS BEEN
PASSED IN FOUR STATES THE STATE
OF TEXAS.
THE STATE OF OKLAHOMA THE STATE
OF VIRGINIA AND THE STATE OF
MARYLAND. THERE WAS NO ORGANIZED
OPPOSITION OUGHT TO THE SAME
LEGISLATION IN THOSE FOUR STATES.
JUST SO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
KNOW WE HAVE BEEN SINCE NOVEMBER
OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN IN
COMMUNICATION AND WORKING WITH
CREE UP WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THEM. OF WE DID
ACTUALLY TAKE AN AMENDMENT IN
THE SENATE OUGHT TO ADDRESS THE
LIABILITY ISSUES THAT THEY
RAISED BUT A NUMBER OF THE OTHER
CONCERNS THAT THE OPPOSITION OF
RACE OR ISSUES THAT ARE GERMANE
TO THE PARTICULAR BILL THAT'S
BEFORE YOU. UP SO WELL BUT WE
WILL CONTINUE TO OF WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION. BUT THE SHORT
ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION IS NOT
WITH THE SPUR.
BUT INCIDENTS.
THAT.
STARTED THIS PROCESS THANK YOU
I APPRECIATE THAT BACKGROUND AND
THEN TO THE OPPOSITION. OF I
MADE THE A COUPLE QUESTIONS THE.
THE REASONABLY PRUDENT STANDARD
IS COMMON IN THE LAW.
MEAN THAT THAT'S WHAT YOU HAVE
IS A STANDARD FOR DETERMINING IF
REASONABLE APPROPRIATE ACTION
WAS TAKEN A SPECIAL AND SOME HAS
A DUTY OF CARE. AND I DO BELIEVE
I'LL BE SURPRISED IF YOU WOULD
DENY THAT HOME INSPECTORS A DUTY
OF CARE.
SO I'M AYE AYE.
MORE OF A STATE I DON'T FIND
PERSUASIVE THAT GOSH WE BE
SUBJECT TO THE REASONABLY
PRUDENT PERSON THEIR LOT WORSE
STANDARDS AND THIS IS. FRANKLY
THE STANDARD THAT IS SO COMMON
BECAUSE IT IS REASONABLE IT
ALLOWS A JURY IN A FAX SITUATION
TO.
TO DETERMINE UNDER THOSE FACTS
SO I AM NOT CLEAR AT ALL ON WHY
THAT IS SUCH A PROBLEM TO BE
HELD TO THE SAME STANDARD THAT
WE WOULD WANT ANYONE.
WHO HAS A DUTY OF CARE CONTACT
TO HAVE?
AS PISSED A STRICT LIABILITY
FOR EXAMPLE. CAN WHAT'S THE
PROBLEM WITH A REASONABLY
PRUDENT BEHAVIOR ON THE PART OF
HOME INSPECTORS.
THE SHOWS WERE SPECIFICALLY
REQUIRED TO DO THIS.
DONE IT AND.
WE HAVE IN THE IN THE BNP CODE
ALREADY WE HAVE A LIABILITY.
AREA A RESPONSIBILITY TO ACT AS
YOU SAID WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY REPORT ON
MATERIAL DEFECTS THAT INVOLVE
SAFETY AT.
HABITABILITY DESIRABILITY AND
VALUE OF THE PROPERTY.
THIS IS SIMPLY ONE MORE SYSTEM
MY POINT IS SIMPLY THAT.
EVEN THE PEOPLE THAT WRITE THE
ELECTRIC CODE. HAVE SAID THERE'S
NO PROOF THAT SAYS THAT MOVING
THE BONDING JUMPER FROM ONE
PLACE ON THE SYSTEM TO ANOTHER
DOES ANYTHING FOR SAFETY.
AND.
.
RIGHT BY BASICALLY ADDING US TO
THE LIST OF PEOPLE.
THAN.
IT IF IT DOES I THINK ALATORRE
LIABILITY BECAUSE WE HAVE A
SPECIFIC RESPONSIBILITY TO
BEHAVE IN A SPECIFIC WAY. AND IF
SOMEBODY CAN MAKE A CASE THAT
FOR SOME REASON THAT WE SHOULD
HAVE BEEN VISIBLE.
THEN DENTAL WORK OR IN THE DEAL
CAP AND THAT'S THAT'S WHAT THE
FACT QUESTION ISN'T AND AT. THAT
HAVE A JURY OR JUDGE YOU HAVE TO
DECIDE.
SO IT SOUNDS LIKE.
YOU'RE.
ISSUE IS POTENTIALLY ALSO WITH
THE ACTUAL STATEMENT SO WOULD
YOU FIND IS EITHER SOMEBODY'S
GONNA MOVE INTO A HOME. OR
PURCHASE A HOME IT USEFUL TO
KNOW IF IT HAS CSSD.
BUT IT MAY LEAVE LEAVE ASIDE THE
STATEMENT THAT'S IN THE BILL
THAT THAT MAY BE THAT YOU KNOW
MANUFACTURERS THINK THIS IS THE
WAY YOU SHOULD DO IT YOU. WOULD
YOU WANT TO KNOW THIS
INFORMATION BEFORE YOU PURCHASE
TO HOME I DON'T THINK MOST
CONSUMERS.
WOULD UNDERSTAND WHAT SHE
ASSIST HE WAS BUT I THINK MOST
HOME INSPECTORS.
WOULD.
WOULD CERTAINLY BE REPORTING ON
THAT ISSUE WOULD YOU WANT TO
KNOW WHAT IF YOU'RE PURCHASING A
HOME.
I WOULD ALREADY KNOW IT BECAUSE
I WOULD HAVE INSPECTED THE HOUSE
BUT ANYWAY THE.
THEMSELVES AND HE TRIES FOR YES
YEAH CANDICE GOT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMUTERS AT THIS TIME
SENATOR GALGIANI DO YOU WISH TO
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK VIVO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND OF THIS
DOES ENJOY A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION AND THERE'S BEEN
A MOTION AND A SECOND. CONSIDER
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
S. B. NINE EIGHTY EIGHT MOTION
IS DUE PASSED LOW AYE LOW AYE
BROWN.
BRUNO ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I BLOOM.
CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU. CHU AYE
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN.
FONG.
GIPSON FONG.
FONG NOT BORING.
GIPSON. GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN. IRWIN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA MEDINA AYE
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE ABILITY.
OBERNOLTE NO TING.
TING AYE.
THE DEVOTE IS THIRTEEN TO TO
BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CYNICAL JENNY MEMBERS WILL GO
THROUGH THE A ROLL AGAIN.
.
AND I ALSO WANT TO. RECOGNIZE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEVIN MCCARTY
WELCOME TO BMP COMMITTEE.
WHAT I'M GOING TO FILE ITEM FLY
ORDER AGAIN AND WILL BEGIN THE
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE WHICH IS S.
B. SEVENTY CENTER DEBATES?
S. B. SEVENTY MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS HOLDEN.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN I.
VOTE IS EIGHTEEN ZERO THE BILL
IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO S. B. NINE
EIGHTY EIGHT.
MOTIONS TO PASS BLOOM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN IPHONE.
HOLDEN.
FOURTEEN TO TO THAT BILL IS OUT
WILL MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE WHICH IS S. B. TEN ZERO
THREE BY SENATOR ROBB.
MOTION IS TO PASS APPROPRIATIONS
HOLDEN.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN I.
EIGHTEEN ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT
OF ON FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
WHICH IS S. B. TEN FORTY TWO BY
SENATOR MONEY.
MOTION IS DAY PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS HOLDEN. MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN I.
EIGHTEEN ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT
FILE AND INNER FIVE WHICH IS S.
B. ELEVEN ó NINE BY SENATOR
BATES.
MOTIONS TO PASS TO THE COMMITTEE
ON HEALTH HOLDEN.
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE.
EIGHTEEN ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT
OKAY THANK YOU RICHARD